welcome to Eastern Kentucky
for the greater part of the last century
this region has been entirely dependent
upon one industry everything was cold
cold cold if you live in this part of
attention it was cold
that's where the money was it ran the
coal mine when I used to hear the word
Appalachia a few stereotypes came to
mind
poverty hillbillies coal and when I
learned that the Appalachian region
voted for Donald Trump I thought my
opinions were confirmed but a recent
trip to the region taught me a few
eye-opening things first its Appalachia
non Appalachia yes of the country turns
to cheaper sources of energy like
fracking the coal industry that's been
so vital to the region is dying and yes
some of the worst poverty in the US is
present there but what my fellow
producer Sanne Michael and I found in
Appalachia was a much more human story
the story of people who are embracing
the change and learning to adapt in
order to survive in order to understand
their story we have to go back to how it
all started my dad worked in the mines
both my grandfather's worked in the
mines I'm a third generation coal miner
my grandfather was a miner and so is my
dad and both my dad's brothers were
working to Colorado kind of coal mine
for 23 years I think almost every man in
my family has been in coal I've been
killed here recently
large scale mining in this county
happens adapting to work and you
couldn't get the colder market previous
to the railroad coming so there was
never any large-scale mining until the
railroad arrived for the greater part of
the 20th century until 2008 coal supply
the majority of all US electricity at
its height the industry employs tens of
thousands of people in Eastern Kentucky
it even built entire towns there like
Lynch and Venom for the sole purpose of
serving the industry
time to Lance Kentucky was born and
raised back it was the largest coal
mining camp in the United States back in
those days we had the best teachers in
our schools we had the best hospitals we
have the best creator and even become
they would even get some of the old
movie stars old western guys come in
here lives you go look at the town now
you'd never think that there were 10,000
people that was in this program
there were many immigrants from Italy to
Wales to Poland who came to work in the
coal mines and black Americans made up a
significant portion of the coal mining
workforce in Eastern Kentucky
we got a call live but people did this
right Mountain Alabama by night to keep
records it wasn't only black and white
yes black wife holy people Indian people
make some people they was like 37
different ethnic groups in a little town
I was born raising my dad began working
in the coal mines during World War two
they needed the coal for the war effort
so actually the miners weren't drafted
because this country needed steel and
steel is made with coal from the late
30s until 45 things were going for
something it's back to work with all
runners of the larger lots of work this
country needed the coal and the mines
would prosper while coal became a
booming industry miners were forced to
work in dangerous conditions and always
at the will of the coal company you know
our dads will displace really they were
displays for the company so where I got
old soul
oh go if you work for Lynch mine you can
get paid
money you can pay like college krill and
you can spin and running away but give
me you have that you call the coppers
store you have a spear caster the
mountain and go get your clothes if that
you got too close they like they're in
the comments below
back when calls are started to come
around here they built coal camps you
can still go to places and see all these
houses that look you know they're
exactly the same lined up in like little
square sections they work all day in the
mines you know the ramp was taken over
or paid for the house the lighting like
if you need to turn a coal for the old
fireplace or whatever that was taken out
and the kids venting realizing that
stuff we just we just out playing and
having a big time
Eastern Kentucky became known as a
battleground for workers rights
particularly in Harlan County known as
bloody Harlan miners fought many of them
to the death in the 1930s and again in
the 70s for better pay and safer
conditions because of their protests
Khomeini became synonymous with union
organizing after World War two the mines
begin to mechanize and that left a lot
of people unemployed so those were
difficult years from just after the end
of World War two through the 50s through
the 60s until 73 1973 was a big year for
the energy industry in arab-israeli war
was raging which led to an oil embargo
in a coal boom across the United States
a boom that would reach peak in 1982 for
the next 30 years the industry would
continue with boom and bust cycle and
coal would remain the lifeblood of
Appalachia for a really long time that
was the only opportunity that a lot of
people around here had you know
education-wise there wasn't really a lot
going on and worse lies there definitely
wasn't a lot going on and when you know
a company comes in and they want to pay
you $20 an hour you know that's a really
good deal for a lot of people who have
been living in poverty for so long
since 2012 the coal industry has been on
the rock and the jobs have continued to
decline
year after year so here we are four
years later and almost all of the mining
jobs are gone in 2015 coal production in
Eastern Kentucky reached its lowest
level since the Great Depression 2000
coal miners lost their jobs that year
alone and in 2016 for the first time
more electricity in the US was produced
by natural gas than by coal with more
than 50 coal companies having declared
bankruptcy since 2013 Eastern Kentucky's
economy is collapsing so will
Kentuckians go down with it
coal jobs in Kentucky are their lowest
in over a hundred years and Eastern
Kentucky is one of the hardest hit areas
so in the next video we'll take a look
at exactly how the decline of the coal
industry has impacted the everyday lives
people living there